Adapting to sudden and unexpected changes
is a core tenet of human survival.
However, abruptly finding yourself trapped
in an apparently infinite extradimensional
pocket dimension in the form of a never-ending
Ikea… well, that can take a brief adjustment
period to get used to.
Callan hadn’t even noticed for the first
few moments, wandering through the aisles,
aimlessly passing aisles of Hemnes and Trysils,
all the assembled display pieces of affordable
flatpack furniture.
It would have been more exciting, shopping
for all the accouterments for his brand new
apartment, if Callan wasn’t being perpetually
reminded that he was moving in there on his
own.
It took him almost twenty minutes of walking
through the row of Ikea products for him to
realize something felt off.
He had hardly seen anybody else around.
In fact, the more he thought about it, there
hadn’t even been any employees in their
garish yellow polo shirts and blue pants at
the front of the store.
Squinting off in the distance, Callan couldn’t
even see the far wall of the store.
Sure, he knew Ikea outlets were big inside,
somewhere between a supermarket and an industrial
warehouse, but this place seemed to go on
forever.
Figuring that he had unknowingly stumbled
out of the store proper and into a large storage
area, Callan turned around and started to
try retracing his steps back to the entrance.
It was after another twenty minutes of taking
this approach that things went from feeling
off to being overtly unsettling.
By the time that over an hour had passed,
Callan was starting to panic, racing through
the seemingly unending store, the rubber soles
of his sneakers squeaking against the epoxy
resin floor as he yelled loudly for somebody,
anybody that might hear him.
Before long, the latest victim to find themselves
lost inside SCP-3008 was hitting the first
existential hurdle that came with being trapped
in the Infinite Ikea.
Callan sat on a display couch – a two-seated
Söderhamn with a chaise longue, in case anyone
was wondering.
He was curled up into a ball, knees tucked
under his chin as he gently started rocking
himself back and forth in a futile attempt
to comfort himself.
It hadn’t yet quite sunk in just how trapped
he was, the thought that he might starve to
death among the endless stock of Söres and
Fartygs.
“The store is now closed.
Please exit the building.”
The sudden sound of a voice startled Callan,
snapping him out of his dread-filled daydream
enough to realize the store now seemed darker.
The lights had been gradually dimming the
longer he had stayed, creating an artificial
night within SCP-3008.
Normally the sign of another person after
being isolated would come as a relief, but
whoever had spoken was nowhere to be seen.
A slow, shuffling moved around the sofa Callan
was sitting on until he finally called out
into the dark.
“Hello?
Is anyone there?”
There was a pause.
The movement stopped for an agonizingly quiet
moment.
“The store is now closed.
Please exit the building,” the voice repeated
as the unseen speaker stepped out of the shadows.
Even in the low light, the creature was horrifying.
Everything about it was just… wrong.
For a split second, Callan thought it might
be an Ikea employee; it was wearing the uniform
after all.
But its bodily proportions were all off, arms
hanging nearly all the way down to the floor,
hands and fingers enlarged and elongated.
As for its face…
it didn’t have one.
The ordinary features were all missing.
And now it was running right for him.
Callan leaped over the back of the Söderhamn
and ran.
His first instinct was to get away and hide.
Checking over his shoulder, he caught sight
of the faceless creature dashing right past
the couch with enough force to knock it over.
In his startled state, looking out of the
corner of his eye at the encroaching Staff
member, Callan tripped over his feet and tumbled
back down to the hard floor.
The creature loomed over him as he tried to
crawl towards a nearby aisle.
Looking up at it, the Staff member was reaching
for him, its big, disproportionate hand outstretched,
trying to grab at Callan as he lay there helplessly.
Suddenly, something struck the faceless creature;
someone barely visible in the dimmed lights
of the store had leaped down from the shelves
of the aisle and swung a makeshift weapon
at the Staff member.
As it connected, the creature was reeled,
stumbling over itself, long enough for the
mystery assailant to take another swipe at
it.
Their weapon, comprised of what looked like
part of a curtain rail with a pair of kitchen
knives at one end, impaled the Staff member,
ripping through its bright yellow Ikea polo
and out the other side.
Striding over to where Callan was still laying
on the floor, awestruck by the display he’d
just witnessed, the figure pulled back the
hood of a rudimentary cloak they were wearing
– fashioned by hand out of Aina curtain
fabric.
Revealing herself with a stern, serious look
on her face, the woman reached a hand out
to Callan, offering to help him up rather
than whatever that faceless creature had wanted
with him.
“It’s okay.
I’m not going to hurt you,” she stated
as she pulled him back up to his feet.
“This is probably all pretty confusing for
you, right?”
Still too stunned to speak, Callan just nodded.
“Yeah, it was for me too,” the woman replied.
“We don’t have long until more Staff show
up, so you need to come with me and don’t
ask questions, okay?”
Seeing him nod again, she took Callan’s
hand and led him through the dark recesses
of the Infinite Ikea.
Stealthily, the pair of them snuck through
aisles, keeping low and ducking down out of
sight whenever more of the Staff lumbered
into their path until they had wandered elsewhere,
clearing the way for them to proceed.
Callan’s new guide seemed to instinctively
know her way around the layout of the sprawling
maze of flatpack Swedish furniture, quietly
urging him to stay close, offering him a hand
up when they climbed up shelving units.
Until finally, they arrived at their destination.
A warm glow emanated from somewhere beyond
a tall, makeshift barrier.
Sofas and cabinets were stacked on top of
each other, forming an intricate wall around
an area of SCP-3008.
And right in the middle of this rudimentary
barricade was a large, two-door Pax Fardal
wardrobe, its back missing, doors inwards,
facing towards the inner side of the blockade.
The guide stepped into the incomplete wardrobe
and gave a specifically timed knock, three
beats with the third following the first two
after a short pause.
From the other side, it sounded like something
was being hurriedly removed from the wardrobe’s
handles, before the doors opened up to allow
her and Callan entry.
Beyond the outer wall, this part of the Infinite
Ikea looked to have been converted into a
small town, with a sign hanging above that
read ‘Decoration, Population: 58’.
There were even more people within, most in
handmade clothing crafted out of scraps of
fabric, along with the remnants of old clothes
from the outside world they’d been cut off
from.
Some looked like they were standing on guard,
carrying weapons similar to the guide’s
weapon, others were sitting around together,
talking casually under the light of Sollefteå
floor lamps.
“Okay,” the guide sighed, turning back
to Callan.
“We’re safe now that we’re inside the
wall so, you can talk again now.”
“Uh, thank you,” he replied awkwardly.
“For saving me, I mean.”
“Don’t mention it,” she smiled for the
first time since they had met.
“I’m sure you’ve got a lot of questions,
so ask away.
I’ll do my best to answer as many as I can.”
“Where am...”
Callan’s voice trailed off, thinking of
a question he wanted to know the answer to
even more than where he was or what was up
with this place.
“Who are you?”
The girl smiled and offered him an outstretched
hand.
“My name’s Kiah.”
Over the coming months, and with a lot of
direction from his new friend, Callan slowly
started to adjust to living inside SCP-3008.
The lifestyle was completely different from
what he was used to before; instead of renting
or buying a house or apartment, the survivors
had established their own little settlements,
using the copious amounts of Ikea furniture
around to construct homes for themselves.
Without access to money – or any need for
it – nobody was self-serving either.
Everyone chipped in and helped each other
out, agreed to take on tasks that would benefit
their fellow survivors.
There was a strong sense of community inside.
All anyone had in the Infinite Ikea was each
other.
They were all in the same situation, and surviving
it was made easier by cooperating.
Kiah took responsibility for showing Callan
around, teaching him all about life in SCP-3008.
When he asked her why she was so adamant about
keeping an eye on him, she replied by telling
him that when she had arrived, she’d been
scared and alone.
Even when the town of Decoration had taken
her in, Kiah still needed to learn all the
basics on her own.
She admitted that she had wished somebody
was there to teach her, and endeavored to
do exactly that for Callan.
She started by telling him what the best time
to head to the food court was.
Every day, all the food in SCP-3008 would
somehow reappear, meaning that everyone could
easily have their fill and survive without
having to hunt or kill each other in order
to eat.
Kiah’s next lesson involved teaching Callan
how to use Ikea stationery to leave subtle
but recognizable symbols around the store,
so that if he was ever lost, he could find
his way back to Decoration safely while avoiding
the Staff.
“That’s the thing about living here,”
she said.
“When we first arrive, we all think we’ve
got nothing.
But this place has food, shelter, tools, everything
we need.
We just have to learn to use what it gives
us.”
As time went on, Callan found himself paired
up with Kiah for patrols.
During the daytime, Staff would wander aimlessly
around the store, far more docile than they
were at night.
To make sure they were ready in the event
of an attack by the faceless creatures, the
survivors mapped out the Staff’s movements,
reporting back to their settlements in case
a large group of them were wandering too close.
The more they went out together, the more
Callan found himself eagerly looking forward
to being in Kiah’s company.
Maybe it was just because she was the first
person he’d met inside the Infinite Ikea,
perhaps because she had saved his life, but
there was something about her that made him
feel a little less sad about being trapped
here.
A feeling that would soon be cruelly ripped
away…
It happened during an otherwise normal patrol.
Kiah and Callan were checking the aisles,
keeping an eye on the Staff, and tallying
every one they saw.
The lights were starting to dim, indicating
it would soon be night again, and the pair
of them agreed it was time to start heading
back to Decoration.
That was until the sudden screeching caught
their attention.
“What the hell was that?”
Callan whispered.
“No idea,” Kiah replied.
“Could be someone else just arrived.”
She gave a hand signal that instructed Callan
to split up; the pair of them moved through
parallel aisles towards the source of the
noise.
It sounded like stone scraping against the
floor, the weight of concrete causing whatever
was being moved to generate a grating, eardrum
piercing racket.
As he moved silently through the now familiar
space of SCP-3008, Callan wracked his brain
about what could be making a noise like that.
There was nothing that heavy or made of stone
within the Ikea, at least not that he had
encountered.
Even Kiah had looked surprised when first
detecting that sound; she’d been in here
for so much longer, so it was telling when
even she had no clue what had made it.
Suddenly, the noise stopped as quickly as
it had started, followed by the call of a
familiar voice.
“Callan, come look at this!”
Kiah called.
“What is it?” he shouted back, trying
to keep his voice low but audible, aware the
Staff might be nearby.
“I don’t know, some kind of statue.
I’ve never seen anything like it in here
before-”
Kiah was cut off mid-sentence, a quick, loud
scrape of concrete against the resin floor,
followed by a blood-curdling scream.
Eyes widening in horror, worried for her safety,
Callan sprinted further down the aisle, frantically
calling Kiah’s name.
As he reached the nearest corner, the scream
stopped.
Her cries didn’t fade, lowering gradually
then petering off, instead her voice just
cut out abruptly, with a sickening, muffled
crack like the sound of bone breaking beneath
the skin.
Panting, Callan whipped around the corner.
That’s where he saw her, lying on the floor,
totally, unnervingly still.
Her head was tilted at an unnatural angle,
the bones of her neck misaligned as blood
dripped from her nose.
Kiah’s body was lying at the feet of something
Callan had never seen since he’d arrived
in the Infinite Ikea.
It was some kind of sculpture, constructed
out of concrete over a metal rebar skeleton,
with a crude attempt at spray painting over
its outer surface.
He had no idea that this statue was often
referred to as SCP-173, otherwise known simply
as the Sculpture.
But then, Callan was more focused on how distraught
he felt at seeing Kiah dead on the floor.
He had never worked up enough courage to tell
her, always worried that it would make things
weird between them.
And now he’d never get the chance again,
would never get to see her smile as he took
on the lessons that she taught him about surviving
in SCP-3008.
Feeling his eyes well up, Callan blinked away
tears.
Suddenly, the Sculpture shot forward, in the
split second that his eyes were closed.
Callan staggered away in shock and stumbled
over, landing on his back on the floor.
As he went to get up, SCP-173 was inches away
from him, having moved yet again of its own
accord.
Carefully, Callan stood up, making sure to
keep looking straight at the sinister statue;
it was getting clear what this thing was doing,
that it couldn’t move while being observed.
Sure enough, as he started to cautiously back
away one step at a time, SCP-173 stayed still,
frozen in place.
Reaching the corner, his eyes stinging, desperate
to blink, Callan took a deep breath, fixing
his gaze on the Sculpture for one moment longer
until…
Turning and sprinting as fast as his legs
would allow, Callan had a few short moments
to blink, sending his tears streaming down
his face.
Behind him, he could hear the same oncoming
sound of concrete scraping heavily against
the floor as the Sculpture gave chase.
Callan rushed down the aisles, grabbing stacks
of flatpacks off the store shelves and pulling
them to the floor, leaving piles upon piles
of mess behind him in a desperate attempt
to slow the oncoming statue down.
Why hadn’t it killed him already?
Perhaps it was just playing with its food.
He thought about trying to get back to Decoration,
wondering if maybe any of the other surviving
settlers had encountered SCP-173 before.
But as he ran.
Callan caught sight of some of the symbols
he and Kiah had left around the store to help
them find their way around.
One of them denoted that there were hiding
spots nearby, and spurred him on to change
course in that direction.
He couldn’t lead the Sculpture back to the
town, not if it could slaughter them all in
the blink of an eye.
Finding a cramped cupboard, Callan climbed
inside and shut the door behind him.
With his knees tucked under his chin, he couldn’t
help but remember the time he had arrived
in the Infinite Ikea.
He had done almost exactly the same thing
when he first encountered a Staff member;
he’d run, and his first instinct had been
to just run away and hide.
That was something about Kiah he had always
wished he could be, she was fearless, easily
standing up to that Staff creature that would
have killed Callan if she hadn’t intervened.
Trapped inside a cupboard, the deafening noise
of scraping concrete outside as the Sculpture
searched for him, Callan felt like he’d
let her down.
It seemed that, despite Kiah’s best efforts
to teach him, he was still scared.
As he sat in the dark, praying the Sculpture
wouldn’t find him, he apologized under his
breath to her.
Callan started replaying every moment he and
Kiah had spent together, partly to keep her
alive in his memory but also so that he could
at least think of something good before SCP-173
found him and broke his neck the same way.
Every lesson about life in SCP-3008, every
one of Kiah's skills she had painstakingly
passed on were all still there, including
the best piece of advice she’d ever given.
“We have to learn to use what this place
gives us.”
Her words echoed in his head, as Callan finally
realized that she hadn’t just been talking
about taking food from the food court or using
flatpacks to build shelters and settlements.
She’d shown him how to navigate, how to
evade the Staff, and that everything in the
Infinite Ikea could have some usefulness in
aiding survival.
As much as it hurt knowing Kiah was gone,
Callan realized she might have already saved
him a second time.
He peeked out of the cupboard door; the Bathroom
section was just a quick dash away, and SCP-173
was nowhere to be seen.
A few moments later, the Sculpture detected
a loud sound; someone knocking things together,
shouting, and whooping had caught its attention.
Unobserved, the concrete creature zapped its
way towards the source of the commotion, moving
quickly over towards the Bathroom department
of the store’s endless aisles.
It came to a sudden, instinctive stop, sensing
eyes were watching it.
Its entire stone body froze, rigidly fixed
to the spot it was standing on.
It didn’t matter that the eyes watching
it this time were its own.
Reflected back at itself in an assortment
of mirrors, SCP-173 was stuck.
Someone had sprung a trap for the statue,
making it so that from the moment it shot
over to its current position, it wouldn’t
be able to move.
It was constantly being observed by itself,
no matter what angle its reflection would
be within its own direct line of sight.
Standing atop a nearby stack of shelves, Callan
looked down at the concrete statue, trapped
in a collection of mirrors that he had assorted
into a ring.
“Hey, you!” he called down at it, hoping
it could hear him even though it was frozen
in place.
“The store is now closed, please exit the
building!”
He struck loudly against the metal frame of
the shelves, hoping it was loud enough to
be heard.
Sure enough, the Staff quickly descended on
the source of the noise.
The night made the feral, hostile towards
anything they sensed to be an outside presence.
They instantly honed in on SCP-173, attacking
it to little avail thanks to its stone body.
Eventually, the group of Staff grew in number,
starting to heave the Sculpture as they went
to remove it from the premises.
Climbing from shelf to shelf, Callan followed
them the entire way; the Staff had no eyes,
so technically couldn’t look at SCP-173.
But he could.
Even through tears, he didn’t blink until
the Sculpture had been removed.
He wanted to make sure.
It was what Kiah would have done.
Now go check out “REAL IKEA MANAGER GOES
MAD WITH POWER IN SCP-3008” a and “SCP-096
VS.
SCP-173” for more videos featuring the anomalies
featured in today’s tale!